Jennifer Lopez ghost makeup-free rocking  sweats but she's still a glam goddess I  really feel blessed the 47 year olds hit  the gym in New York City on Wednesday  sporting a topknot black shades a  long-sleeved cropped top gray sweatpants  and black high-top sneakers and yeah she  still looked as fierce as ever  got the hourglass for you baby she deal  is JLo puts in the work to get those  killer curves and she's proving women  can be sexy at any age in 2014 the booty  singer dish to et's sister show The  Insider about feeling good in her 40s  I've come more and more into my own self  every single day and I grow and I learn  and I have more wisdom and at the end of  the day you realize life is short and I  have to live I have to live I have to do  me I have to feel good about myself and  I don't think there's anything wrong  with that in any way shape or form  [Music]